if you've been following my channel for
a while then you probably know that i
like to talk a lot about the various
technologies out there that people are
using for data science
r python sas sql
julia i've covered all of that but i
haven't talked about
power bi yet until today i'm richard and
this is richard on data
[Music]
so i like a lot of other people who
create data science related content
am a huge fan of open source
technologies
and for data science creating as much
output as possible
using a reproducible programming
language i'm far from the only one who
has that view
so hadley wickham that's the chief
scientist of our studio
and a prominent professor gave a talk at
the association for computing machinery
in chicago
about how you can't do data science in a
gui
but power bi is a super popular tool in
the business intelligence
as well as data science worlds and it
has the ability to integrate with r and
python
such that you can write scripts in those
languages
directly inside of power bi so it was
certainly created with
data science in mind at least to a
certain extent
so for those of you out there who are up
and coming data professionals
i'm going to talk about whether or not
you should learn power bi
now the answer is a little bit nuanced
and my answer might actually surprise
you a little bit
to answer that question i'm going to
dive into various things like
what it is and what the high level
capabilities are
how popular it is what the relative
learning curve of it is
how it should fit into a data
scientist's general stack of knowledge
and then overall is it worth your
investment before i do that though
please take just less than one second to
smash the like button to this video
because that really does help my content
reach a larger audience
also in the description of this video i
will have a link to my patreon account
so if you guys would be willing to
support me that way it would be
massively appreciated
as one final disclaimer i'm not
affiliated with microsoft in any way
shape or form
i'm just a guy who makes youtube videos
so first
just some background on power bi the
very first version of it was released in
2011
but in its current more mature version
it was released to the public around
2015
and the goal with it is to help you
create interactive visualizations and
reports
dashboards and other business
intelligence goodies
now it is considered proprietary
software
but you can do a ton for free just by
downloading power bi desktop
and the link to do that will obviously
be in the description actually there are
versions of it with advanced cloud
deployment controls
enterprise-wide bi and general things
like that
but for your layman who's just trying to
learn it it shouldn't cost a dime
contrast that with something like
tableau which at the time i'm recording
this video
the only thing you can get for free is a
14-day trial
as far as popularity and its overall
adoption in the broader industry is
concerned
power bi is not a programming language
that's important to understand
so it isn't tracked by something like
the tyobi index
and it's honestly extremely difficult to
find any kind of breakdown on its
popularity and the number of job
listings for it
in the data science world specifically
however just as a point of reference a
study of data science jobs done from
2017 to 2019
which you can see on kd nuggets found
that tableau
was listed as the eighth most listed
technology
in data science jobs posted on indeed
coming in at just
under 10 000 job listings now power bi
was not included in that same analysis
but it's important to understand it is
the second place
market leader of the business
intelligence market behind tableau
and just anecdotally i've seen it in use
at
both of my last two data science jobs
which were at
small and mid-sized companies
respectively
now none of this is to serve as any kind
of rigorous
scientific analysis but all that to say
is
you're very likely to run into some data
science jobs out there
that involve power bi now let's talk a
little bit more about why you'd be using
a tool like power bi in a data science
role in the first place
like i mentioned earlier the core appeal
there is going to be
so that you can create interactive
visualizations and dashboards
much like the kind of thing that you
might do using tools like plotly
and dash and shiny in python and r
respectively but of course the
capabilities go far beyond that
you can read data in from a whole
variety of sources
ranging from excel spreadsheets text
files and csvs
sql server databases azure blob storage
and even html tables available on the
web
once data is loaded into power bi then
you can use what's called power query
now for those of you who are unfamiliar
with that from an excel context
it's basically a data preparation and
transformation
service so you can do a lot with that
without writing
any code but for more complex procedures
yeah you're gonna have to write some
code and for that
power bi offers two different expression
languages
and those are dax and power query m
also known as the m language more on
those in a minute
all of that to say you have a fairly
nice array of options for manipulation
of your data
and getting it into a generally clean
format so that you can do more fun stuff
like creating interactive visualizations
but wait it gets even better
power bi can integrate directly with
either r or
python and so you can use those two
languages
either for your data transformation
purposes or even incorporating r
or python visuals directly into a
dashboard
but then i'd add here just from a
motivational standpoint
you may have some familiarity with r and
python
but that doesn't necessarily mean that
you're an expert in
shiny or dash because those are very
complex packages with enormous learning
curves
now like i said you've got two different
expression languages in power bi
those are dax and the m language and
both of these languages are fairly
excel statements maybe sequel like
and i think overwhelmingly for most
people it's going to take a lot less
time to get really proficient at those
things
than it is for full-fledged programming
languages like r
python all that to say most people can
probably learn how to create a
reasonably aesthetically pleasing
dashboard in power bi
with capabilities to filter and slice
and dice your data however you want
in much less time than it would take to
get really good at something like that
in shinier dash so with that let's dive
a little bit more into the learning
curve for power bi
and the amount of time it'll probably
take to get really proficient at it
honestly you can probably get to the
point where you can build
something simple and straightforward in
as little as an hour
i'll have a link in the description of
this video to a video by
youtube creator kevin stratford and now
that video is 28 minutes long
but i've gone through it myself with the
full example in it
and i can virtually guarantee if you go
through the full 28 minutes of it
you'll know your way around as well as
be able to create some simple
visualizations
also have a link to a video from youtube
creator avi singh
and this one is an hour long it's a
little bit more detailed and he gets
into things like writing dax code
but again i've gone through that one
myself and i can personally vouch for
if you go through that one you're going
to have at least a beginner's level of
comfort with power bi
but like anything though once you hit a
real-life project
that's when you're going to stumble
around and hit some roadblocks
but that's also where you're going to
accomplish the lion's share of your
learning
so it'll take time those tutorials also
don't walk through things like
r and python integration that data
scientists will be interested in
and obviously there's no tutorial out
there that's going to make you a master
at anything
without going out and doing the actual
thing but i think overall
the time it takes to master power bi is
nowhere near
the same level of time that it takes to
master a programming language like
r or python so everything i've described
in this video
so far has been overwhelmingly positive
maybe you're asking yourself at this
point of the video
if there's some big catch that i'm about
to drop and no
not really there's not and in fact if
you're more interested in business
analytics compared to data science
and your core skills are sql and power
bi
honestly i think you're in a pretty good
position to get yourself hired somewhere
but for data scientists though i've
talked so far about
how easy power bi is to learn compared
to r
python but i think it's important to
realize
it's not a substitute for a full stack
programming language
like r or python and it's also not a
substitute for having a solid
fundamental knowledge of sql
earlier this year i did a video on a
study pathway for up-and-coming data
scientists
and i laid out in that video that step
number one people should learn if they
don't know it already
is statistics then number two is sql
and then number three is either r or
python
and i do think that for a lot of people
they're going to be best
served by first getting themselves
acquainted with things like
the other one of our python linear
algebra
the principles of user experience and
machine learning
having said that a core tenant of data
science
is being able to tell compelling stories
using powerful visualizations
and to that end power bi is a great tool
similarly maybe you're somebody who
works in a data science capacity
and you find yourself tasked with
creating an interactive dashboard
and you have to do it pretty quickly if
it comes down to learning new
technologies
it's probably going to be faster to
learn power bi
compared to something like dash or shiny
but here's the thing
business intelligence and data science
do have tons of overlap
but they are not the same thing data
science is going to bring you problems
like dimensionality reduction
text analytics time series modeling
just a lot of different things like that
for which the first tool to attack those
problems
is just not going to be power bi so
where i think power bi
will make sense for most data scientists
is to supplement a solid fundamental
set of capabilities and toolkit that
consists of things like
sql and one or both of our
python so in short it's important to
remember that there's tons of different
types of data scientists out there and
it varies a lot depending on what area
you're in
what sort of industry you're working in
and your specific organization
you might see a lot of data science job
listings out in your area that call for
power bi
and similarly maybe you are the type of
data scientist
who really loves creating fancy and
colorful dashboards and visualizations
and to that end even though there's tons
of different technologies that us data
scientists could pick up for the first
time
or at least even sharpen our
capabilities in
especially when you couple that with the
fact power bi
is fairly easy to pick up it may very
well be
worth the investment of your time to
learn and get proficient at
again my recommendation is to learn
statistics
sql and one of r or python first
and during that and after the fact i am
a really big believer in focusing on one
thing at a time and getting really good
at it i think for a lot of people
at some point in their data science
journey power bi
is really going to be worth it it's just
a question for you
based on your own interests and what
organizations around you are doing
where you want to prioritize it so
thanks for watching this video
if you enjoyed it and you found it
entertaining or useful
please consider sharing this video again
smash the like button and also let me
know down in the comments below what you
think
and if you're a data scientist who's
used power bi let me know what your
experience with has been
then i'll see you all in the not so
distant future until then
richard on data